TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, everyone.
Timothy Jordan here for
one last interview--
this one with Francoise,
a principal scientist
here at Google.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
[LAUGHS] How are you?
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS:
Very good, and you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I'm doing so good.
The festival has been
amazing, and we've
had the opportunity to
talk to a lot of people
about what they do.
And that's why I'm
excited for this moment
here because you do
some really cool stuff.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: All right!
Yeah, it is cool!
I agree!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So why
don't we give everybody
just an introduction to the
work that you do around machine
learning and the input.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Yeah, so
I work on speech recognition,
and I work on keyboard input.
So speech recognition, you
all know what it's about.
Sundar has been talking about
our progress in Voice and how
we've lowered our word-error
rate quite a bit--
Google Home and all that.
And I've been working on
speech for the last 12 years
at Google.
And then, more recently, maybe
the last two-three years,
I've been working
on keyboard input.
And when people think
of their keyboard,
they think it's
something very simple,
where they just take the
mobile keyboard on their phone
and they just tap the letters
of what they want to spell.
But in reality, if you
want a good keyboard that
really understands you
and corrects your mistakes
and predicts the next word
that you're going to type,
it's pretty complicated.
And there's a lot
of machine learning
that goes into
keyboards as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, that's
one of the things when
you were talking
about this earlier,
is that it's a
common misconception
that machine learning
wouldn't apply to the keyboard
because you're just
hitting buttons.
But that's actually
not true at all.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: No,
it's not true at all.
And a keyboard is very
interesting, because it's
such a complex
product in itself,
because you can do a lot
of things with a keyboard.
You can tap on the keys, you can
swipe what you want to write,
and then you can even
click on the microphone,
and then you can speak to
your keyboard, too, right?
So the two modalities
come together there.
But doing a good job at
correcting your typos,
yet letting you type new
words that the keyboard maybe
doesn't know about,
and then learn
those words and those
phrases for you,
and then being able to
predict the next word
or the next phrases that you're
going to type so that you don't
have to type them, you
can just say, oh, yeah,
that's what I meant, click--
that takes a lot of
machine learning.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
One of the other
aspects of your work
that I find really
interesting is
I end up talking to a lot of
machine learning researchers,
and they're just
blazing new ground.
It's really
interesting, but it's
like very theory
and theoretical.
But what you do-- is
you have problems,
and you've just found that
machine learning is a good way
to solve them.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Right.
So the way that I like to
think about these problems
is, I have a technology to
build, and it has many facets,
and there are many things
that we need to optimize.
It can be the machine learning.
It could be the UI.
It could be the
infrastructure that's
behind it that nobody sees.
And so what we're
really trying to do
is to understand the
pinpoints for the user--
where are the places where
our users are wasting time
and are getting frustrated?
What are the places
that they enjoy instead?
And then trying to
understand those problems,
then we look at what
are the right solutions
for those problems.
And sometimes, the solution
is just sweeping a parameter.
And sometimes, it takes
like a really complex piece
of machine learning.
So we're just picking
the technology
that matches the problem
that we have to solve,
and we improve the technology
one step at a time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
really interesting
to kind of have that
perspective of, its very
pragmatic about
machine learning.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS:
Right, right.
Exactly, exactly.
And I think it's a good
approach because, once you
know exactly what--
the hardest part is
really figuring out
what is the problem that
you're trying to solve.
And I think a lot of developers
are struggling exactly
with that same problem.
It's, what is it that
I'm trying to solve?
How am I formalizing that?
And then, what is the best
tool to solve that problem?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
So there's another aspect of
your work I want to bring up--
it's the last one, I promise--
which I find really interesting.
And you call it deep
internationalization.
Can you tell me what that is?
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Yes,
so as you may guess,
I'm not a native US
American speaker.
I grew up in Belgium.
Belgium is a country
with French, and German,
and Flemish.
I learned Italian when I came
here to the United States.
So I care deeply
about languages.
And we have found
developing those keyboards
that a lot of countries in the
world and a lot of languages
are not well represented
in mobile keyboards.
What I mean by that is that
there are a lot of people
in the world, sometimes
tens of millions
of people, who speak a
language and would like
to write to their
friends in that language,
but that language is not
supported on a keyboard.
So what do they do?
Either they go back
to another language--
so maybe I can not
type in French.
I will go back to
English because it's
OK my friends
understand English too.
But that's not
what I want to do.
I want to speak
French with my family.
And if we happen to speak a
much more distant language that
is not well
represented, we wouldn't
have the luxury of
being able to talk
to each other in
our own language.
So that brings us
into this space
where we think it's
not just about bringing
a few tens of languages
into our keyboards
and into Google
technology in general.
It's about hundreds
of languages.
It's about going
beyond 1,000 languages.
There are in the
world 1,342 languages,
according to linguists, that
has more than 100,000 speakers.
So you can imagine.
And if you go into
even the deeper end,
it would be in the
6,000-7,000 languages.
And so I really have a
passion for bringing as many
of those languages online as
possible and progressively
enabling technologies like
speech recognition and keyboard
input to more and
more languages.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
the way you design
an app is just a
little bit different
if you're trying to design
for all of them, right?
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Yes.
So the app itself,
we try to keep
things as general as
possible because there's
no way you can scale to
hundreds of languages
if your infrastructure
is not general
and your modeling methodologies
are not as general
and scalable as possible.
And that's where machine
learning actually is very
helpful to us because before we
had machine learning to solve
our problems, we would really
[? hurt ?] good things,
and you would see pieces
of C++ code that would say,
if language equal
German, do this, right?
And that's not what you want.
There is no way to scale that.
With machine learning,
you essentially
have the algorithms that are
data independent and language
independent.
And then the data
is the piece that
contains the knowledge
about the language.
So now there's
this nice interface
between algorithmic
work and data work.
And so once you have
the right to algorithms,
it's just a question of bumping
data from different languages
into them to create a new
capability in those languages.
And if you improve
your algorithms,
all the languages
improve at the same time.
So it's a really nice
synergy as long as you
can establish that boundary.
And with machine learning,
that's very easy to do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, and
it sounds very sort of,
once you get the
right perspective,
things start to fall into place.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Exactly.
You really want to
build from scratch
with this thinking of, how am
I going to internationalize
my product, my technology,
but not just to five languages
or just to hundreds
of languages.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I think
that's about all the time
that we have, but thank you
so much for joining with me
and talking about all this.
Is there anything
else you'd like, say,
if you could see some developers
on the other end of this camera
that would love to be
doing the kind of work
that you're doing now,
what's some of the stuff
that you'd tell them
to get started on?
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS:
I think the best work
that you do is
through when you're
passionate about the
thing that you're doing.
So I would think
for each developer,
if they are-- and I assume they
are-- passionate about what
it is that they're trying to
develop, dig deep into it.
Just don't be satisfied
with something
that's average quality.
Keep digging and digging to
try to understand your product
the best you can and what your
users want the best you can.
And then keep
developing from there,
and everything will go well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Awesome, Francoise.
Thank you so much.
FRANCOISE BEAUFAYS:
You're welcome!
Thank you!